I don't know if purpose is something
that you necessarily find you know I
don't know if the world has your purpose
one of the best things that you can do
is getting to know yourself stripped of
all the identities the world gives you
do not a start protecting your life
everybody don't deserve you everybody
don't deserve access to your life need
motivation watch atop dam with believe
nation
he's Trent Shelton and here's my take on
his top ten rules of success enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one
find your true purpose when someone gets
has a purpose or a dream that they
pursue and they get a taste of it and
then their entire identity shifts into
something else how do they figure out
what their purpose is now I get that
question a lot right how do I find my
purpose and my thing is this I don't
know if purpose is something that you
necessarily find you know I don't know
if the world has your purpose
alright I think we go like where is it
that gives it down the street you know
or do has it and so I think when we look
for like that we can end up lost our
finding something that might be a
pretend purpose or something that are
you know are once like I really want and
we say okay this is my purpose no I
think you are purpose as a person that's
what I've been saying that said that it
kind of changed my life so I say I am
purpose you were born on purpose I mean
of course you know the nerd statistics
about like you the chance of you being
used like 0% chance and your parents
have to come together the sperms
whatever so like I'm like your if you're
looking for a miracle you're that
miracle it's like do you realize that so
you are purpose and when I really
embodied that and and really like
understood that I realize that my
purpose isn't rehab time because that
can be lost my purpose isn't football
because that can be lost my purpose is
you know Trent Shelton at my pure Who am
I because when I understand that I can
go in any placement right I feel owes
our placements I can go in any of those
placements and actually live my full
potential actually make a difference
actually use my life to bring betterment
in this world
rule number two get to know yourself
talk a little bit about getting
comfortable with you your own skin who
you are right I think one of the best
things that you can do is getting to
know yourself stripped of all the
identities the world gives you
you know yeah who are you without the
title yes you know who are you without
the significance that the world gives
you and I have to figure that out
because of course like you said when I
was a football player even now with
rehab Tom you know the world will give
me these titles of Who I am this is your
identity you have to be this person and
when you lose that you will lose
yourself and so I literally I call it
protecting my piece I did it earlier out
here I mean a beautiful place that
protects you it was gonna be you I do it
every single day I protect my piece by
diving in to who I am right my struggles
mine securities things I'm tempted by I
get to know myself better and I think a
lot of people they don't get to love
themselves I don't enter look they don't
spend time I mean I tweeted this out not
to my snapchat this out today and
someone says I can't be by myself yes
yep and I think one of the greatest
successes to be able to be by yourself
and still not for the long rule number
three stay focused there's people out
there that don't want to see you do good
as you know there's people out there
that don't want to see you happy don't
want to see you accomplish anything
don't want to see you grow there's
people out there that don't want to see
you be everything that you want there's
people out there that are threatened by
your greatness
they can't handle you they know they
can't compete with you they know they
can't beat you so their goal their plan
is to make you beat you they want to
take you off of your game Italy that's
why they don't hate your way
that's what its own negativity your way
drumming your way nonsense your way to
get you off your game they want to take
your focus off of what matters most to
what does it matter it up because they
want your position realize that when
somebody wants your position they will
do anything they can to get your
position and a lot of times we fall
victim to that because we fight their
hate with hate we allow our energy to be
taken off of what matters most to them
don't be tricked out your position
stay focused keep your composure they
want to make you lose it keep your
composure what's composure not being
distracted by distractions all the great
ones in life from sports to just be
great period one thing they had was
composure no matter what people do it
them
hey negativity gossip drama rumors no
matter what they do it there they stay
focused on where they were trying to go
they stay focused on their goals stay
focused on their dreams stay focused on
that purpose nothing can stop them from
moving forward nothing could stop them
from making it happen so let nothing
stop you from making it happen rule
number four get disciplined my
definition that discipline is probably
the easiest definition ever just get
good at saying no to the things that
don't get you yes and that's very hard
because there's temptation out there
there's just bad habits that are just
waiting for you to start doing so maybe
it's your friends maybe you got to start
saying no to your friends and maybe you
know your friends aren't bad for is it's
just that when you around them they're
not doing the things that you want to do
or they're not at a place where you want
to go like I had to leave some friends
behind not because they were bad to me
it's just that hanging around them under
that mindset was contagious and I knew I
wasn't strong enough to be around them
because I would fall victim to that
lifestyle right so I have to let them go
I'll used to like to fart like I said
like how'd you stop partying and like I
was like I used to love partying and
going out like I probably still do like
it to be honest with you like it's fun
but I just tell myself like where is
this leading mm six seven hours in the
club and you know you're exactly and
it's like where is this really going you
know it's just like a false sense of
fulfillment that actually moves me
nowhere and so think about that like
that's discipline discipline is you know
you're saying no to the cake or the
pilots you really love like this place
not saying no to things you hate that's
easy
so it's saying no to the things that you
love or you like that won't get you to a
place where you would love to be also if
you want more videos highlighting
excellence in the black community check
out by 254 black excellence it's free
the link is in the description below
everything I didn't want to do is what
got me to where I'm at today
anything we can accomplish anything with
our two hands and just putting in the
work rule number five take control what
did you start to do to rehab you so you
got a lit up to know yourself better but
what were some of the things you did so
I took control that things out good
control mmm you know um I think you know
for me at least I don't know if anybody
else feels like this watching this is
that we try to control the things at our
shows and it's like it drives you crazy
so I asked myself what can I control me
and so I can control my physical mm-hmm
I can control my mental so of course I
went to the gym I turned up my physical
fitness to a whole nother level to do I
turned up my mental to a whole another
level that means I got around people in
for me it was uncomfortable because I'm
an introvert yeah asking for help are
getting around crowds of people like
that makes me uncomfortable even to this
day as a speaker yeah but I knew I had
to push myself outside of my comfort
zone to create a comfortable life but
that makes it easier rule number six
stop protecting your life man listen I'm
gonna be real with you you got to start
protecting your life everybody don't
deserve you everybody don't deserve
access to your life like what you around
is what you will be like like I'm very
picky about what I place my life around
who I place my life around my circle is
very small because I cannot afford to
allow certain people certain mindsets
mess up mine certain information mess up
my whole day like some of us we surround
our lives around people who do nothing
but gossiping they bring that to your
life around people who are about nothing
but drama then they bring that to you
like then it affects you it stops your
growth and put pause on your purpose and
if you like me I can't afford that so
when I see negative people it's hi and
bye I keep it pushing because I cannot
afford to catch with that guy when it's
negative people are calling my phone
I'll make it quick
I play for them but I keep it pushing
because I know I'm not strong enough
nobody is strong enough to avoid that if
you consistently be around that I
which you place your life around
consistently will influence it period
rule number seven hack fear how do I
develop a mindset a belief that my
purpose is something that I should go
all-in on I think one thing that you can
do okay I think fear is a part of that
right like fear like you might not go
all-in because you're fearful love like
you say you might not you know be as
great as someone else or you might not
you know succeed in that field so for
one understanding what fear is which for
me it's it's basically just creating a
normal result from a situation you
haven't experienced yet so you're
telling yourself what is going to be
before you ever go to do you're gonna do
it
so of course you're not gonna go do it
you know so if you believe this result
is gonna happen it's gonna be bad
exactly I'm gonna fail I'm gonna look
stupid everyone's gonna make fun of me
then you're probably not gonna want to
do it exactly or be able to give your
food like it's like playing football
like you go out there and like we're
gonna lose or I'm have a terrible game
more likely have a terrible game it's
gonna be hard to operate a high level so
I've just learned to I always say like
if fear was a door and behind this door
was all this negativity things that I'm
saying like I'm gonna lose I'm gonna
suck I'm never gonna walk through that
door so in order for me to walk through
the door even though the door is super
scary I have to make empowering things
on this side of the door right I'm gonna
learn I'm gonna grow even if I don't win
it's gonna be some valuable in it so let
me walk through this door right even
though it might not be perfect I'm still
gonna find growth inside of it so to me
that's like a small little trick to like
really hack fear and get over fear and
also of course it's Brendan talks about
this a lot like not just repetition but
like really like focus repetition like
finding that area and say you know what
I'm gonna get better at this because
sometimes fear comes from not being
prepared you know I mean if we go back
to sports if I'm going to a game didn't
watch tape then do any of this stuff I'm
people ready scared or taking the test
you know so preparation also is a is a
part of that and so I would just tell
people you know you got it you got to
figure out all that how to get over fear
but just go out there and do it and one
way to go out there and do it I use
leverage questions with my life so I'll
go all out bro like this might be over
the top
but say I saw I was running running it
was a saddle next to running I don't
know what the trail was my friend took
me on like a back trail and as I'm
running you know it sucks it's uphill my
heart rate is like zone 5 and I just
tell myself like if I quit on this then
I'm not living it for rehabbers if I
quit then I'm putting the mindset in
myself that's a quitter and my son and
my daughter are gonna feel that like I
go over the top with it so I don't give
up and so what leverage questions it can
be anything
I give me the simple Everest question
that tomorrow's not promised that's one
of the best ones right 150,000 people
die every day tomorrow is not promised
so if I'm not going after it then I'm
gonna die incomplete I'm gonna die being
a person that I wasn't created to be
like I want to meet the greatest me I
want to meet my full potential so I I
told hub Tom this yesterday about I
would literally go to cemeteries at one
point and it seems super creepy
like I'm weird but I will go to
cemeteries after my friend committed
suicide death became so surreal to me
because it was somebody that was like
next to me I will go to cemeteries
sometimes with my friend and just walk
around and be like bro we're gonna be
here one day Wow and it's like you look
at the tombstones you realize that deaf
have no preference you know different
ages it's five year olds or 80 year olds
it's black it's white it's women as men
its children it's adults and it just
made it super surreal for me so gang
leverage right in your life like what's
something that's gonna make you move
that's all you have to do is move take
that first step that's the most
important step in the journey and listen
you're gonna fall in your face you're
gonna be embarrassed but everybody who's
experienced greatness has been through
that rule number eight just be real
forget perfection it does it forget it
it doesn't exist and I know in a social
media error it's it's popera it mean
it's popular right I mean it's like
nobody's really posting their struggles
and I'm not telling you to go on a
soapbox and post all your struggles
online and I'm not saying that but just
be real beats okay to show that you're a
human it's okay to be embarrassed I mean
when I first started speaking it was ten
people that showed
my family and my friends what I was yeah
I was happy about that and I just see so
many entrepreneurs and foreigners trying
to fake it today make it rule number
nine don't give up on you I'm gonna get
straight to the point no matter what you
lose no matter who you lose there's one
thing that you can't lose and that's
just so I see so many people lose
themselves give up on themselves because
of other people listen to me don't give
up on you because they gave up on you
you hear me don't stop believin in you
because they stop believing in you don't
let what they think influence what you
know it doesn't matter how many people
quit on you you hear me
it doesn't matter what's important is
that you don't quit on you the key to
your journey is to never let how they
feel about you change how you feel about
yourself better walk in your shoes so
stop giving their opinions the power to
direct your path and rule number ten the
last one me for a very special bonus
clip is get stronger from pain it's easy
to smile on the Sun out but can you
smile when it's raining straight up I
always tell you guys adversity exposed
someone's true character like
everybody's about that life at first but
when that light show up you're gonna see
exactly what they bow for real strength
wasn't built in your strongest moments
it was built in your weakest ones a
strong person is just a personal didn't
surrender during their hardest times
they let those hard times build them and
make them stronger straight up this day
and this strength is nothing but
payments be repaired pain has its
purpose and I'll promise you its purpose
is not to break you it's to build you
now I've got a special bonus tip on how
to find commitment that I think you
couldn't enjoy but before that it's time
for the three point landing questions
let's go from just watching the video to
taking action here we go question number
one how will you get stronger from the
pain you're going through right now
number two what will you do this week to
hack your fears and number three how can
you better protect your life I don't
have perfect days you know I'll be the
first I had days where I'm lazy I have
days where at times where I doubt myself
all these things so everything I talk
about like I could practice it myself
sometimes I'm making video I'm preaching
it to myself but how I keep a
championship monster
I've studied high-level people like I've
been around of course athletes I've been
around people as yourself and we all
have these qualities like everybody has
them so number one is commitment and
commitment Stan loyal to what you said
you were gonna do long after the movie
set is left yeah being your word exactly
so when that move leaves who are you
gonna be so some people might be
watching this podcast is gonna be hype
or whatever and like I'm changing
everything which is great but we know in
real life it's who are you gonna be
called the New Year's Eve mindset right
new year new me so you gotta find
commitment and I would just challenge
people like find something small to stay
committed to
I mean fitness is a great thing say hey
I'm gonna go to the gym you know maybe
two days a week three days a week and
stay committed to that because if you
can't be committed to the small things
don't expect big results and big things
to happen
if you want to see Prince EA's top ten
rules check the video right there next
to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there the garb is that you listen to on
the radio the trash you see on TV the
bush that you hear from the people that
you hang out with it rubs off on you